hola bienvenidos una vez más a esta
emisión de canadá en las américas café
el espacio que cada semana les ofrece la
sección en español de radio canadá
internacional con esta imagen de
montreal que nos muestra aunque parezca
mentira la llegada de la primavera a la
ciudad que ha comenzado oficialmente
esta semana pero efectivamente ahí está
la imagen gris parece ser que el
invierno se resiste a irse aunque poco a
poco va dando espacio va dando cabida no
sólo se resiste ese porque vuelve
nuevamente a nevar esta tarde o esta
mañana 15 centímetros de nieve pero con
menos fuerza con menos intensidad
porque habían anunciado unos 20 o 30
centímetros y al final la cosa terminó
55 y 7 o sea que estaba colgada en
montreal pero hay lugares en las
provincias de las marítimas donde
efectivamente van a caer 20 a 30
centímetros de nieve lluvias y vientos
fuertes y más es por eso que aquí
estamos en el estudio yo no las chapman
hablaban de escuchar
pablo gómez barrios hola que tal mi
nombre es luis laborda y tenemos a dos
invitados con los que vamos a hablar en
pocos minutos más se trata en este caso
de juan carlos garcía en la punta que es
el director y miguel aránguiz de manuel
y aránguiz que es actor
y están ligados ustedes a un nuevo
proyecto de serie
webber exiliado para que nos vamos a
ocupar
en muy pocos instantes en esta emisión
les damos la bienvenida a todos los que
nos siguen a través de facebook live a
través de nuestro sitio en internet www
brc y net punto sea y también por
supuesto a que nos siguen a través de
nuestro canal en youtube que es cada vez
más popular va sumando poco a poco más y
más adeptos y no por nada estamos en
esta nueva escenografía más al estilo
televisión que radio real exacto a los
antiguos estudios de radio de las a los
cuales estamos muy acostumbrados pero
nos vamos acostumbrando tenemos otra y
ese estreno para tu casa para los dos un
poco diciendo unos minutos antes y
nosotros vivimos realmente una
revolución tecnológica de estos últimos
años que pasamos de la onda corta que
era nuestro fuerte en aquella época
pasamos ahora estamos en televisión es
decir todo lo con todo lo que eso
conlleva e implica como cambios
tecnológicos y maneras de producir los
problemas
a representar los peinados que mirarlas
estamos mirando también bueno y decíamos
esta semana es la semana en la que
comienza oficialmente la primavera aquí
ahí tiene nuestro amigo leonardo gimeno
que en esta ocasión está del lado del
control alguna imagen que nos va a poner
en pocos instantes para mostrarnos que
hay otros colores
está perfecta porque son las primeras
flores que salen cuando el hielo se va
[Música]
detrás del parlamento de ottawa es el
parlamento y eso qué es eso puede ser
tan eso no es monte o esa no es moldear
el lago de los castores si sea
es muy muy asistido precio cuando llega
en verano y en invierno porque en vera
en invierno se convierte en una cancha
de patinaje y en él y en el verano pues
es tomar sol y refrescarse y cuáles son
sus planes para la primavera hay alguna
actividad que están esperando puedo
realizar que piezas que no son posibles
primera actividad siempre estoy
esperando que se vaya en la nieve porque
empiezo a caminar me gusta venir
caminando al trabajo son seis kilómetros
de ida seis kilómetros se hace fácil
a esas horas tempranas de la mañana ya
me hice 800 kilómetros de un tiro y
camine 800 kilómetros entonces hacer 6
kilómetros no es nada no es nada eso
estoy esperando 800 kilómetros entonces
fue compostela 6 fueron en 35 días 900
kilómetros casi vivos pablo algún
proyecto que tengas para la primavera
algo que estás esperando podría ser que
le estabas haciendo en invierno también
exactamente pero tuvo una lesión que me
impidió continuar
venir en bicicleta a que al trabajo pero
puedes volver nuevamente a sacar mi
bicicleta y venir a trabajar en
bicicleta y trotar no que lo que me
encanta me corta hay que decir que es un
señor muy valiente en este estado porque
no es que la bicicleta en invierno a mí
me cuesta como esperando por ejemplo el
invierno o verano siempre al pie del
barco
no he intentado imitar un poco durante
este invierno pero hemos hecho poquitas
cosas y muy reducidas muy muy poco
convincentes al lado de esos asados que
se manda leonardo tanto en invierno como
en verano bueno pero a pesar de todo la
primavera ya está aquí esperamos que se
exprese de una vez por todas en el
territorio de montreal donde nosotros
mismos también y en las provincias del
este del oeste norte en todos aquellos
que habitan
y canadá y por qué no en el hemisferio
norte también y decíamos que teníamos
que tenemos perdón dos invitados los
nombramos nuevamente se trata de juan
carlos garcía y manuel arango ellos son
actor y director o director y actor de
una serie web que se llama que se llama
exiliados y que está ambientada en
quebec en cada episodio se presenta a un
personaje que ha dejado su lugar de
origen para radicarse aquí en estas
tierras y eso le obliga a comenzar una
nueva vida se trata de un proyecto que
nació con la intención de contar
historias diferentes esa es la idea
inspiradas por otros
a ver qué pasa en la vida de esa gente
que nos cruzamos a diario en las calles
en las diferentes ciudades de quebec y
de canadá habrá en total ocho capítulos
que serán difundidos cada semana y antes
de comenzar a hablar con juan carlos y
con manuel vamos a ver algunas imágenes
en vídeo de lo que han estado ustedes
produciendo
ah
es muy rico
[Música]
bueno eso es apenas la presentación de
los exiliados de qué se trata juan
carlos si es eso justamente era esa
necesidad de esa urgencia de empezar a
contar un poquito nuestras historias no
de contar historias de gente que está
aquí que viene de afuera y que de alguna
manera los vemos los que usamos en la
calle de pronto a veces me gustaría
conocer un poquito más de estos
personajes no y claro al mismo tiempo
degradado
poder para mí como realizador o director
productor empezar de alguna manera a
poder empezar a trabajar con actores
latinos también con gente que venga de
afuera que ahí que esté que este
proyecto me ha permitido encontrarlo no
encontrar y vemos que hay un montón un
montón de gente que viene de afuera
artistas actores músicos y y eso estoy
súper súper contento con este proyecto
ese nivel cuando ustedes dicen exiliados
a qué se refiere exiliados políticos
exiliados de otra naturaleza y que
podrían definir un poco sirve exiliados
yo creo que exiliados era un estereotipo
digamos muchísimos llamar exiliados para
poder abarcar todo a la gente queda
afuera y no necesariamente político del
país y al mismo tiempo una metáfora del
exilio que también vivimos
con nuestras historias de la soledad por
ejemplo el exilio de stars
un lugar diferente y siempre es la
historia de una persona en cada capítulo
sí y con qué criterios eligieron a cada
persona
primero a nivel de la escritura del
escenario ya tenemos ideas tenemos
algunas historias que queríamos contar y
de pronto pues nada después se buscaban
los los actores y hacíamos el casting
entramos a nuestro equipo y uno de esos
actores los tenemos
del personaje en el caso en el caso no
era el que protagonizó yo
es un exilio muy particulares la soledad
el aislamiento que significa alejarse de
toda una realidad
es un hombre es probablemente que vive
ella muchos años aquí y que trata de
esconder su soledad y se ve enfrentado
al drama de tres que
que irse del departamento donde está
todas historias donde ha vivido con su
mujer
y no sabe qué hacer entonces es un
exilio más bien interior
exactamente vive solo y ese es el
misterio
[Música]
usted originario yo soy de chiles de
chiles que eligieron también los
personajes en función de una
representación de algunos países de
américa latina o eso no no en el fondo
esos son historias historias de que a
veces son como en el caso de la historia
que protagonizó y que escribimos juntos
la historia de una soledad porque en mi
caso yo yo he trabajado mucho aquí
y siempre fue el exilio
siempre fui a uno no deja de serlo el
exiliado por excelencia digamos entonces
en un momento dado nuestros proyectos y
nuestros proyectos van a
a que no tengamos que certificar en la
imagen en nuestra presencia
para que podamos ser lo que somos todos
seres humanos que conviven en una
realidad entonces exiliado es como el
punto de partida para que dejemos de ser
exiliados porque es el punto de partida
para contar una historia
porque el formato web o porque se busca
la web como canal de difusión yo creo
por el medio de producción
por ejemplo estas series de ads
totalmente independiente o sea no hemos
tenido un pequeño subvención del consejo
de artes de quebec que nos ha permitido
terminarlo pero no tenemos toda la
estructura como debería costar una serie
web o sea no teníamos dinero y entonces
y esa vuelvo a repetir esa urgencia de
que debe hacer algo a veces nos
encontramos con actores gente que quiere
hacer cosas y de pronto decimos cuándo
vamos a hacer y entonces creo que hacer
un largometraje es súper complicado
mucho dinero y es muy riesgoso también
entonces con una especie de laboratorio
de experimentación y de un primer
encuentro creo que la serie web nos
permitía esa flexibilidad no de poder
tener y justamente por eso cada cada
historia es un personaje diferente
porque no queríamos abarcar con uno solo
durante toda la filmación porque no
teníamos pues nada el dinero para pagar
a los actores por ejemplo no vemos pero
digamos que no lo podíamos al equipo
técnico tenerlo durante 7 15 20 días por
al entonces tenemos que firmar no se
firmó un episodio cada un mes cuando la
gente podía y un día máximo de filmación
su episodio de manuel fue un solo día y
en general tratamos de hacerlo un solo
día porque son actores claro saben cómo
hacerlo en un día y también pero tipo
claro que es un para mí como realizador
seguro que queremos tener la mejor
cámara
el mejor sonido el mejor
no sé todo el tiempo también pero
dijimos bueno a veces es que
deja de dar unas cosas y a ir más a lo
que es dice las historias y empezará a
mostrar los actores entonces los actores
por ejemplo no no había necesidad de
tanto un avión nuevo tanto casting
tampoco una acera gente que lanzábamos y
los que se acercan los que querían como
facebook gente interesante facebook es
inmenso
si la gente que haya trabajado y aquí
que tienen mucho que han hecho unas
cosas en sus países sobre todo también
son todos de origen latinoamericano si
le queríamos dar esa oportunidad también
de y se habla también español francés
inglés y queríamos también mostrar un
poquito lo que es el montreal de hoy día
donde estamos viviendo ahora vamos a
seguir conversando pero podamos saber si
si leonardo nos envía otro de los vídeos
que hemos separado para mostrar el
trabajo que ustedes vienen realizando
podemos hablar con él durante este este
la semana que viene ok lo siento
y de la exigencia a la que se encuentran
sometidos muchas veces para poder
acceder a una micro que indirectamente
también porque tampoco queremos cariño
en él
contra eso es un poco de pobre
inmigrantes
yo creo que partimos de eso mostramos
ciertas realidades como esta del que
vamos a trabajar y esperamos el autobús
que hay mucha gente lo vive que querer
si llega mucha gente que no tiene
papeles tienen que pasar por esto pero
no era el objetivo no era eso no nos re
contar un poco la misma viralidad
entonces era eso entonces era más a
tocar cosas más humanas también que todo
el mundo puede vivir los sueños el
trabajo la casa la familia
que podría ser un latino o alguien que
venga de aquí también y justamente ayer
en encontrarnos amigos que es con las
cuales trabajo que ha visto la serie que
no sabían esa realidad por ejemplo que
es increíble que sea que también les
muestra hoy yo no sabía que puede que la
gente esperaba y se cree una especie de
discusión también entonces es súper
simpático lo que no tengo en claro es la
acción y se está emitiendo o se va a
comenzar a emitir ya salió la cosa como
cada viernes podría salir un episodio a
las 5 más sabiendo lo lanzamos entonces
salió pasado el 8 de marzo luego viene a
ser que salió la semana pasada y hoy día
sale ilusión entonces un episodio por
por semana así me da tiempo de
terminaron los otros todos los otros
edición y eso implica que ya tienen
algún otro proyecto en carpeta sí bueno
ahora que se decía que hay que empezar
yo creo que ya a veces esa
a buscar los financiamientos siempre es
muy complicado entonces yo creo que
ahora hay que empezar a hacer los
proyectos y construirlos
no nos queda otra si queremos empezar a
hacer y mentalmente tocar al lado la
puerta de los difusores y todo entonces
el hecho de utilizar la web como
herramienta de dilución implica no
solamente bajar los gastos y facilitar
el trabajo de producción como
universidad referencia sino también que
implica llegar a un público distinto
posiblemente tal vez un público más
joven que el que habitualmente consume
este tipo de contenidos a través de los
medios tradicionales como podría ser la
televisión que se plantearon a la hora
de intentar llegar con este contenido a
ese público tuvieron en cuenta
claramente a quién se estaban refiriendo
algo algún objetivo específico de lo que
querían decir modificaron el lenguaje y
la estética de lo que estaban haciendo
para intentar encontrar ese público o no
yo creo que la
para el amigo de la exigencia en la
misma
es decir tiene que haber una calidad
cinematográfica como si estuviéramos
haciendo cine
es decir uno de los méritos que de lo
que yo he visto que a ellos con cargos
hasta entonces la calidad de la
fotografía como si estuviéramos en un
cine
la calidad de la actuación tenía que ser
la mejor posible no hay caso
no hay tutía no se puede decir mira como
es para web
actuamos un poquito más en una escala
que llega llegando siempre la misma
entonces lo que nos interesaba en las
discusiones y en nuestro trabajo en
particular la escribí con con él
la historia que escribí con él
era la humanidad porque con la humanidad
de los personajes podíamos llegar a un
público muy vasto eso lo que nos ha
interesado y es cierto que tiene una
chica cronista que es muy joven y que ha
planteado problemas de adolescente con
respecto a sus padres pérez pero en
general no nos ubicamos a una calidad no
nos gusta el cine fundamentalmente así
que buscamos la misma calidad que si
estuviéramos haciendo cine
y lo que me di cuenta en los dos
episodios que tuve la oportunidad de ver
es que hay pues esa transposición
estamos en canadá estamos en montreal
pero también están los recuerdos de los
de los personajes no entonces tienes a
uno que de repente pues está en algún
países sudamericanos sé donde donde hay
represión está la chica que tiene
también el su pasado no tiene la
persigue aunque esté acá en canadá
entonces pues me pareció interesante esa
transposición de de un lugar donde de
dónde viene y de lo que están haciendo
aquí en montreal canadá
la realidad es que todos como
inmigrantes vivimos esa doble dualidad
también siempre a veces recuerdos o
sonidos que nos atrapan en la calle o
olores que nos hacen recordar siempre en
donde de dónde venimos entonces de si
fue interesante jugar un poquito como
este con esos 12
momentos temporales ahí vemos otra
secuencia que es lo que estamos viendo
si con carlos pues hay ese los
personajes que trabajan en un lado a
otros
y de pronto me gusta esa escena porque
ahí es donde se usa la radio en la radio
empieza a hablar un poquito
de estas radios que como se llama radio
google basura que de pronto empiezan a
hablar de cosas no hay salón son los
inmigrantes fuerte que no que hay un
lado que nos separa que no están muchos
archivos si sigue así vamos a tener un
camión de tacos acá pero son cosas son
textos que hemos escuchado en la radio y
que a veces no tomamos conciencia de eso
trabajamos en el trabajo de dar a tocar
no tocar menos que de pronto eso
entonces sería y también siempre está
con recordando era una ex militar que
escapó y que de pronto llegó a montreal
y esa ya de tratar de recuperar su vida
también ese discurso de las generaciones
recién referencia es una realidad es que
van más a dos por ahí no tanto aquí en
canadá por suerte pero si en muchos
otros destinos que reciben gran cantidad
de inmigrantes que ante la primera de
cambio empiezan a ser vistos como una
amenaza esa temática fue abordada y en
ese capítulo por lo menos en esa escena
queda muy en claro su nacionalidad
porque tampoco queremos entrar
esto es un largometraje para explicar
todo esto pero si fue sutilmente ese
toque ese tema no y de pronto sobre ti
ahora que hablamos de todo lo que es
facebook acceso socio se puede ver
también comentarios mucho más directos y
fuertes que vemos ahora ustedes hacían
referencia el hecho de que la mayoría de
los actores son inmigrantes qué pasa
entonces con el lenguaje con el idioma
en el que está hecha esta producción
porque si se trata solamente de español
se apunta un público muy específico o se
incluyen otras lenguas es un poquito
claro que sea un poco arriesgado pero
queríamos empezar a comentarnos un
poquito de nuestros orígenes y que
hablar el idioma pero hay como manuel en
su episodio habla español un poco pero
después habla con la trabajadora social
en francés completamente todo el tiempo
no entonces hay una escena que se llama
15 que es un quinceañero que es un
poquito la confrontación de una niña que
prácticamente nació aquí que habla
francés inglés y español y sus papás en
español
entonces justamente es eso de mostrar un
poquito esto de
de que no digamos que en esos tres
idiomas también pero sí
perfecto antes de continuar nuestro
diálogo quería proponerles que leamos
algunos mensajes de nuestros oyentes ya
sea de los que nos llegan a través del
correo electrónico oa través de el
servicio digital en facebook y otros
medios por ejemplo yo no era qué mensaje
tiene si tengo un mensaje que viene de
damaris arencibia william y dice hola
soy cubana y junto con mi familia
vivimos en chile estamos muy interesados
en el programa piloto del norte de
canadá y pide preguntas y nosotros
podemos poner los formularios para
postular por esas visas entonces desde
ya decimos que no ese no es nuestro
trabajo nosotros informamos somos
periodistas pero esos formularios están
todos en el sitio de inmigración canadá
efectivamente el ingreso en español
también está en el sitio de inmigración
canadá ya está traduciendo los
documentos también algunos al español yo
quiero dar cuenta de una carta que nos
llamó la atención estos últimos días
porque llegó a través del servicio
postal
o postal que cada vez es menos usado en
nuestro caso al menos para este tipo de
comunicación y nos la envía un amigo de
desde méjico se trata de margarito de
santa cruz que vive en bartolomé de las
casas en guadalajara y él nos envía
saludos a través de su carta y además
una almanaque con una vista muy
atractiva de un lugar justo para hoy en
la primavera que va a caer bien no viene
mal sería de agrado de todos nosotros
poder cambiarlo por la nieve que aún
permanece en las calles de la ciudad
pero bueno ya mejorará el clima acá
también pablo algún mensaje si luis
tengo acá mensajes de nuestros oyentes
tenemos a nelson contreras rincón dice
saludos desde barranquilla color a un
saludo nelson tenemos otros mensajes de
javier gonzález nunca hay méxico
y bueno javier nos dice muchos saludos a
todos que disfruten la primavera que
allá sí se nota y felicidades por la
nueva coreografía del estudio saludos a
los invitados dice también nuestro amigo
de méxico javier gonzález nungaray y
gustavo lucas dice saludos desde la
ciudad de melo departamento de cerro
largo en uruguay
hoy faltan paloma y leonardo pero a
paloma ya la vi en el programa en
francés con stefan para mí aunque sí que
tenemos oyentes que escuchan también el
programa exterior en francés así que son
los mensajes que tenemos que tenemos de
nuestros ser oyentes muchísimas gracias
creo que nos queda un vídeo más si
leonardo lo no puede enviar vamos a ver
una última secuencia del trabajo
exiliados que vienen haciendo nuestros
invitados del día de hoy esa secuencia
que habíamos comenzado a ver hace unos
instantes que termina siendo una broma
unos chistes criminales
trabajando entonces
pero finalmente solamente es un poco
luego aparece el personaje que a presión
el primer episodio que se conocieron y
que parecía que queríamos intentar hacer
esta secuencia de cada personaje por
ejemplo
wilson que creaba el carro es el
protagonista el próximo episodio de hoy
día porque en continuidad quería hacerlo
pero después se hace más y se complica
un poquito las cosas pero hubiera sido
interesante eso pero bueno
cada personaje totalmente cada episodio
es totalmente diferente del otros
exiliados es solamente uno de los
trabajos de cascas films que es la
productora que si antes se hicimos
algunos cortometrajes y llamadas
nocturnas que fue trabajo mucho viajo
mucho los festivales eran un premio de
mejor actriz en argentina
después tuvimos amor perfecto amores
difíciles carne quemada gaviria entonces
todavía en formato corto entonces ahora
nos vamos para el largo espero pronto y
siempre a través de la web
esos eran cortos que se hicieron antes
años pasados que eran que dejaban mucho
en festivales esto del jueves ahora
estos recientes nuevos exiliados de
nuestro primer trabajo que si no que
hacemos en el web ahí vamos si es bueno
creo que todos los próximos trabajos si
no no todo van que era en web ahora
entonces es un medio muy interesante que
nos permite poder repartir y que pueda
dejar a mucha más gente los proyectos
desde cuando existe la productora de
café en 2000 2004 en el primer
cortometraje que hicimos porque más o
menos 2004 decir que eso está
consolidado consolidada saldo poquito a
poco eso es un mensaje es que estábamos
conversando al principio acá con
nuestros invitados de la onda corta y de
lo que hacíamos nosotros en la onda
corta y tengo aquí un mensaje que nos
envía juan buitrago él dice saludos
amigos de radio canadá internacional les
comento que soy un aficionado a la
escucha de las diferentes emisoras
nacionales entre ellas la radio canadá
internacional que escucho desde cuando
emitía en onda corta yo tenía 10 años y
los empecé a escuchar en un receptor
sanyo de dos bandas onda media y onda
corta y actualmente los escucho en
internet la evolución llegué a enviarles
varios informes de recepción ya que
practicaba el 10 sismo y en estos
momentos estoy escuchando canadá en las
américas ya en descargue la aplicación
para poder escucharlos en mi celular
bueno espero que sigan progresando en
todo en todo les escribo desde bogotá
colombia su amigo y oyente de siempre
juan buitrago me suena muchísimo cuando
y trago me recuerdo de cartas que le
enviaba hace muchísimo tiempo en el
mensaje de juanes un testigo fiel de lo
que establece que al menos recorrido lo
que falta aún por recorrer porque el
cambio aún no se ha cristalizado no ha
terminado sigue sus procesos recién
comenzamos a
adaptarnos a esta nueva escenografía a
las luces a las cámaras etcétera de
nosotros mismos estamos descubriendo el
avance en nuestra propia misión en un
momento dado serán los hologramas y
vamos a estar en el salón de dientes
bueno y para ir cerrando el diálogo con
nuestros invitados cuáles son los
proyectos que les espero el futuro en
este momento no tenemos ya una reunión
el lunes para comenzar la escritura del
próximo proyecto que ya iríamos bien a
cerrar el ciclo de exiliados porque
nuestro interés como te decía recién
y demostrar que aquí todos tenemos
derecho a vivir es que no importa el
acento no importa lo que importante es
que somos todos parte de una realidad
que se llama muy grandes
una magnífica realidad tiene el quebec
en canadá entonces eso sería nuestro
nuestro próximo proyecto
elaborar una serie de episodios en los
cuales habrá protagonistas
quebequense de origen gente que viene de
otra parte y que conviven como lo
hacemos todos los días
y eso va a estar recién en sus pasos
iniciales a partir de la reunión que van
a tener la semana próxima
perfecto bueno les agradecemos desde ya
la visita no se vayan quédense con
nosotros pero les agradecemos haber
estado aquí y les deseamos mucho éxito
con no solamente con exiliados con todos
los proyectos que inicien con chaca
films y esperamos que en la próxima
ocasión puedan estar nuevamente aquí en
este piso como se dice en televisión
contándonos de esas ideas nuevas y de
esos contenidos que buscan llevar un
mensaje a una audiencia que espero yo
vaya creciendo cada vez más sin invitar
a todos los oyentes también de todas
partes del mundo porque está todo en
español
prácticamente hay subtítulos subtítulos
en español francés inglés entonces pues
nada que vayan a ver dejar en monistrol
y en facebook para que vayan a verlo
perfecto gracias gracias a ustedes antes
de pasar a nuestros temas de la semana
les invito a leer un mensaje más de
nuestros oyentes para ver si podemos
darle cabida a los distintos mensajes
que nos han llegado en los últimos días
por acá no tenemos otro comentario pero
aquí tengo un mensaje que envía jose
roberto ávila pino él dice hola soy
cubano tengo 23 años soy del primer dan
en kickboxing y jk ve que entre
paréntesis m m
fui campeón de tiro en mi escuela y
quisiera alistarme al ejército
canadiense necesito saber si hay que
vivir en canadá o si reclutan personas
fuera del país y esto era con relación a
una noticia que nosotros publicamos acá
en radio canadá internacional y que era
el ejército de canadá levantaría
requisitos de ciudadanía para aumentar
y sus efectivos sí pero como dijimos la
semana pasada es decir esa posibilidad
se brinda a personas que estén viviendo
ya en canadá se deja caer el requisito
de la ciudad de ciudadanía pero hay que
tener la sección de la mente es decir
para decir entre años sencillos no se va
a traer a gente de afuera para que pueda
sumarse a esta posibilidad o esta
propuesta porque en el proceso de
inmigración si le explicamos rápidamente
a las personas que nos están escuchando
se sería que bueno cuando llegas llega
con una visa de inmigrante recibido acá
bueno lo que llegan como inmigrante hay
otros que llegan como refugiados pero
los inmigrantes tienen que estar acá
durante tres años más o menos antes de
poder aplicar a la ciudadanía canadiense
entonces es en ese caso donde se
levantaría este requisito de ciudadanía
para poder aplicar para
el efectivo o sea del ejército o de la
real policía montada de canadá
exactamente yo no era con esa un mensaje
te quedó algún mensaje entre los que
tenías así hay otro mensaje acá es
carlos rueda y dice hola soy colombiano
y mi familia y yo estamos muy
interesados en el programa de
inmigración hacia canadá que tengo que
hacer para recibir estos beneficios
al sitio de inmigración canadá y ahí
tiene toda la información y si no es en
las embajadas de sus países respectivos
pueden ir allí y esta información está
disponible también para ellos en ese
lugar perfecto vamos a pasar a la última
al último tramo de nuestra emisión
porque nos quedan escasos 10 minutos y
le vamos a presentar los temas que hemos
estado trabajando a lo largo de esta
semana lyon ahora vos hiciste un un
trabajo arduo largo extenso sobre un
personaje muy particular si es una
historia que tiene varias etapas es la
historia de una mujer yo puse como
título de sobreviviente de trata sexual
a ultramaratonista y activista
excepcional contra el tráfico humano es
un poco eso lo que la historia el
subtítulo sería el regreso a la vida de
norma bastida ella es nació en culiacán
es una zona en una zona donde ella nació
es era pobre era una zona agrícola que
después se fue transformando ya
por la violencia y se fue transformando
por el narcotráfico la historia es que
ella a los 11 años sufre abuso sexual de
parte de alguien de la familia la
historia continúa en ciudad de méxico a
los 17 años ella se va a la ciudad de
mexico
quiere salir de esa historia y en la
ciudad de mexico se inscribe para
estudiar y es secuestrada por una patota
en la ciudad que la quería vender a una
trata finalmente logre escaparse estoy
hablando muy rápido y es una historia
más larga
finalmente también
decidida a irse totalmente de mexico
para evitar esas situaciones que ya
estaba viviendo acepta la oferta de una
amiga de una amiga de una amiga que le
dice que había trabajo en japón entonces
ella se baja paul con un grupo de chicas
de mexico el contrato de trabajo decía
que iban a trabajar sirviendo en
cantinas en bares como camareras cuando
llega a ella japón se encuentra con otra
realidad es parte de la trata él cuando
llega ya la venden a un mafioso japonés
que tenía millonario y le quitan el
pasaporte en fin hay una toda la
historia que se desarrolla ahí y ella
finalmente sale de esa situación de
japón después de unos años y llega a
vancouver y ahí es donde comienza otra
historia completamente diferente se casa
con un canadiense tiene dos hijos pero
siempre recibió un tuvo un título
empieza a trabajar la vida va muy bien
para ella pero cuando la cosa parecía
andar bien a los 11 años oa su hijo le
hacen un análisis médico y se dan cuenta
que tenía un problema muy serio en la
vista y que iba a quedar ciego ella deja
todo eso
para ocuparse de su hijo y hay que decir
que también norma era alcohólica de
noche
digamos ahogaba sus penas con el alcohol
mientras sus hijos dormían por todo lo
que había vivido pero nadie conocía su
historia y de repente ella dice sale a
correr empieza a correr nunca había
corrido en su vida a los seis meses se
clasifican para la maratón de boston que
todo pues algunas años es largo
clasificarse para el maratón de boston
necesita requiere tiempo que exagere eso
lo sabes muy bien finalmente empieza a
correr y participa en una dieta gran
maratón que son y se convierte en la
mujer más rápida de la historia en 17
maratones en siete continentes en siete
meses hace ese recorrido hizo corrió mil
272 kilómetros y mientras corría
recaudaba dinero para la fundación que
lucha contra la ceguera en canadá
entonces esa es un poco la historia como
ella va saliendo de eso y finalmente
también forma parte de una
un grupo de mujeres seleccionadas por
ópera en eeuu como que se llama un
documental madres excepcionales estuvo
junto con hillary clinton y otras
personas
finalmente norma en esos momentos se da
cuenta de que había algo que no andaba
mucho con ella y era que se había
autoimpuesto un silencio sobre su vida
pasada para protegerse de todo lo que
había vivido y se da cuenta que no va
más la cosa que algo se está quebrando
en ella y decide y eso me cuenta ella la
historia decide contar lo que le había
pasado a su familia por su familia
tampoco sabía de la mejor manera que
ella conoce que era corriendo
entonces agarra se pone una mochila y se
va de vancouver a mazatlán en el 2012
corriendo entonces fueron 78 días 80 90
kilómetros por día y ahí es donde cuenta
su historia y a partir de ahí hay como
una especie de liberación en ella bueno
y después bate el récord guinness conté
en el 2014 al hacer al culminar el
triatlón
el largo del mundo y ahí sí nado pelado
el pedaleo y corrió 6000 km durante 65
días y esto para visibilizar el problema
de la trata entonces hay toda una
historia aquí de resiliencia extensa qué
formato largo es un formato de
información pero es una historia de una
mujer muy bien y puede nuestro público
ya acceder a ahí y enterarse de la
historia de esta mujer pablo no nos
queda mucho más tiempo y muy rápidamente
sí bueno todos sabemos que hubo un
atentado en nueva zelanda el 15 de marzo
pasado
un supremacista blanco entró en dos
mezquitas y disparó sobre los fieles que
estaban en ese momento en su oración en
sus plegarias mató a 50 personas en fin
una tragedia entonces tuve la
oportunidad de conversar sobre ese tema
con
[Música]
hasan que es un líder espiritual
musulmán o aquí en montreal y teniendo
en cuenta de que hubo aquí también en
quebec una tragedia parecida el 29 de
enero de 2017 cuando un supremacista
blanco quebequense entró en una mezquita
en la gran mezquita de quebec y disparó
también contra las personas como 6
muertos en este caso en muchos heridos
entonces estuvimos conversando sobre las
similitudes en que en cómo se
relacionaban de qué forma se podría
relacionar lo que sucedió en nueva
zelanda lo que sucedió aquí en quebec y
él decía que hay muchas formas de
relacionarse y sobre todo primero porque
somos seres humanos segundo en el caso
de ellos porque somos son musulmanes y
porque somos todos canal quebequenses
canadienses entonces él dice que
uno de los datos curiosos fue que en
este atentado que hubo en nueva zelanda
este supremacista blanco terrorista
tenía escritos sobre una de las armas el
nombre de el atacante de aquí de quebec
entonces que no lo nombró pero que todos
conocemos entonces él dice decía me
decía en entrevista el imán a shanghai
que eso quiere decir que el tipo estudio
lo que sucedió aquí en quebec y tuvo el
tiempo de poner el nombre de esta
persona acá entonces él dice que en
lugar de exportar nuestros valores de
humanidad de fraternidad y de calor
humano estamos exportando la violencia
porque esto sirvió de ejemplo este tipo
para cometer esta masacre entonces pues
la entrevista está en nuestro sitio
internet y los invito a escuchar r6 net
punto sea
y aparte los invito a escuchar una
entrevista que le hice a isaac navón
serfaty que es una especialista en
comunicación que habla del atentado en
nueva zelanda pero desde el punto de
vista del rol que juegan los medios y
específicamente los medios sociales en
la difusión de este tipo de derechos de
actos terroristas y de mensajes de odio
porque como ustedes saben y ellos generó
gran revuelo y el ataque que se produjo
hace ya una semana nueva zelanda fue
difundido en directo a través de
facebook entonces facebook ha sido
criticado una vez más por darle cabida a
este tipo de eventos y por convertirse
en promotor de alguna manera de actos de
violencia de este tipo y este profesor
de la universidad de ottawa habla sobre
el tema pero a su vez resalta el hecho
de que no se puede hacer caer toda la
culpa en los medios de comunicación sino
que los usuarios y consumidores los
medios sociales tienen gran parte de la
responsabilidad porque son ellos los que
replican esos contenidos y los hacen
circular entre
de amigos relaciones que tienen dentro
de los medios sociales y plantea la
necesidad de repensar la estrategia de
los medios porque veníamos hablando hoy
un proceso de cambio que se está dando
inclusive en nuestra propia emisión y él
dice la comunicación está cambiando hay
que cambiar las reglas hay que repensar
las reglas de juego para que esto no
siga ocurriendo la entrevista está
también ahí en otro sitio en internet
disponible para que ustedes puedan
ingresar con todos estos contenidos los
que le hemos hablado con los contenidos
que ha producido toda la sección a lo
largo de la semana en nuestro sitio www
rs y net punto se ha y ya nos queda
demasiado tiempo me avisan apenas 30
segundos solamente para agradecer
entonces a nuestros invitados manuel
aránguis y juan carlos garcía por haber
estado presentes aquí gracias pablo
gracias a leonora gracias
próxima a todos los que nos siguen a
través de facebook live que recibe el
punto sea
youtube chau hasta la semana que viene
[Música]